david peterson he started against the
cubs at wrigley field on april 21st metz
lost that game 16-4 but he deserved much
better just a real shabby defensive game
for the mets that evening going on the
on the headsets to the replay center so
there's got to be some kind of an issue
about a rule or maybe
a facility uh are they do they not have
good communication in which case they
have to shut down the other teams
communicate right we've seen that happen
many times right the umpires came to the
headset to verify that the cubs replay
system is operational and apparently it
is
peterson a head-on two and contreras
blacks won the other way mckinney coming
toward the line and grabs the line drive
for the first out of the night
swing of the miss and with a 96 mile an
hour fastball
peterson goes upstairs to strike out
bryant two down
the 1-1 hit haunt on the ground the
first right to alonso he'll trot to the
bag and plenty of time to retire the
side it's jay garrietto sinker slider
curveball chain job for
jake arrieta really aggressive attacking
the strike zone last time out a lot of
first pitch strikes a good jump on the
heater really good movement on his two
seamer
let's hit on the ground right side they
get one there alcantara safe at first
lid door beats it out now it's a bit of
a struggle
that's hit to short they get one there
back to first double play
and arietta gets exactly what he was
looking for
granted
and he pulls one down a third a chance
for two vr that's stuck in his glove
guillory with a turn and they turn the
double play the 1-1 bouncing ball up the
middle but right to lindor behind the
second base bag he's got it throws out
hayward side retired
a dribbler off the bat of billy mckinney
picked up by wisdom a third and he guns
to first in time
hit to third wisdom backs up
hey he's got an arm huh
[Applause]
and arietta gets him right there one two
three go the mat
one out alcantara grounded to shortly
door to his left gets in front picks it
throws to first in time to get alcantara
silgaard goes to second and out two outs
here in the third one ball one strike
throw to second
out at second sogard gets picked off to
win the inning by david peterson
here comes the 02 now to guillerme
swing and a miss arietta gets another
strikeout eddie 02
tap back to jake who handles it
underhands to riz
mariznick glides back hauls it in and
that's that
[Applause]
no score first pitch contreras it's a
high fly deep left center dominic smith
is under it shy of the track makes a
one-handed catch on his right side
bryant lifts one to right mckinney with
plenty of room
two batters two fly balls two out three
two coming and he hits it on the ground
into the shift he or may
plays the hop
and throws out rizzo
[Applause]
bounce towards first
and arietta there's another ground ball
for lindor one away
dom rips one into right field in the
midst of their first hit of the night
and a swing and a miss
so arietta gets the punch out no two out
of two on and now james mccann
mccann hits one toward the middle base
hit
smith around third he'll score the first
run of the game mariznick's throw is
offline
kicks away long enough for mccann to go
to second james mccann with an rbi
single brings home dom smith with the
first run of the game and it's one
nothing new york mckinney going from
first to third and mccann taking second
on an error
now pilar the batter
lar lines toward left center field this
one heads for the gap and it lands for a
base hit mckinney scores so does mccann
right behind him he comes home two run
double for kevin pilar and it's a three
run fourth inning for the mets who lead
three to nothing
chase is a high fast ball and peterson's
got to strike out his second of the
night the 1-1 swinging a drive in the
air to left smith broke back now win
he's there and he makes the one hand
catch two men away
oh two coming and gets the ground ball
right to lindor
side retired
the one
first rizzo handles it
one up one down and it'll bring up lynn
dorth
in the year left field bryant good jump
nice catch two down two up two down and
dom smith will be the better now the
pitch swinging a high fly ball straight
away center it's deep marissa going back
at the track at the wall it's gone home
run dom smith so smith
who has hit jake arrieta very hard in
the past has broken out of an over 20
slump against arietta tonight with a
single and now his fifth home run of the
year he hits that one to dead central
and the mets have a four to nothing lead
well the mitz thanks in part to david
peterson who has bounced back
beautifully so far through five innings
sogar pops one up and vr
right there waiting for it
[Applause]
one out
with one out and half flies one out to
right mckinney coming toward the line
under the warning track and reaches back
to get it that became a little more
complicated at the end for billy
struck him out
for the first time in his career david
peterson throws six scoreless innings
the back-to-back walks issued by nance
and brandon drury will come up to pitch
it with two men on
lined up the middle base hit
[Applause]
and he's safe brandon drury with an rbi
single as a pinch hitter to make it five
nothing new york one away seventh inning
five nothing minutes rizzo has grounded
out twice
and rizzo drives that one right field
that one way back in gone wow into the
top deck anthony rizzo with his eighth
and the cubs are on the board no doubter
from big rizz
he's enjoying that trot around the bases
that ball was crushed wisdom has hit a
whole bunch of home runs since joining
the big league club
wisdom cracks went on the air deep left
center field back toward the wall this
ball's got a chance gone cubs go back to
back they're getting back in the game
patrick wisdom with his ninth of the
year and now it's a 5-2 mets lead
sound the trumpet said when diaz is
coming in five to two
eighth pitch of this at night
struck him out
99 away
[Applause]
struck him out
got him on the slider two man down
so now the cubs are down to their final
out and here's anthony rizzo who broke
up the shutout
he struck him out and the ball game is
over edwin diaz strikes out the side of
the ninth to save it for david peterson